it's one of the most famous buildings in
the world instantly recognizable from
the outside but 88 years after it first
opened the Empire State Building is
getting a new look and it starts way up
at the top so show me where the hundred
and second floor is so we're gonna go
all the way to the very top that's the
hunter second floor of the summit and
the pinnacle
they ride up the elevator to the newly
reopened Empire State Building
observatory and this is the view when
you reach the top it was closed for
nearly ten months during construction
but not anymore
after opening last week welcome to the
world's most famous building and of the
impressive in the gym 102nd for 360
degree unobstructed views of nursery on
the old observatory was much different
there used to be air conditioner units
and would come up to about here and
block much of the view now they've
changed everything and they've installed
these floor-to-ceiling glass panels that
are about 200 kilos each and there's 24
of them that give you this panoramic
view of New York City while the Empire
State Building receives four million
visitors a year for more than 100
different countries it's increasingly
facing competition for tourists like
from the newly opened vessel structure
at Hudson Yards on the west side of the
city and the observatory that opened in
2015 at the top of the one World Trade
Center and that's why the Empire State
Building is in the final phase of a
four-year 165 million dollar renovation
it includes new exhibits and displays
highlighting the history of this
skyscraper and its depiction in movies
while there's no shortage of tall
buildings and city managers here hope
the new views at the Empire State
Building are unlike any other Gabe rose
Ando al Jazeera New York